c'est parfait nous revenons donc
maintenant avec le soleil c'était tout
un programme c'est un mode de vie ou un
curriculum vitae tout à la fois c'est
une chanson choisir beaucoup de choses
et presque rien les chansons c'est
vraiment quelques notes de musique de
trois mots et puis ça peut devenir tout
un univers c'est une chanson qui existe
depuis longtemps dans votre vie vous il
a chanté depuis quand je chante depuis
aujourd'hui je vois que c'est le premier
jour que je la chante pour
pour ce qu'on appelle le public c'est à
dire les gens qui nous écoutent et avant
c'était pour vous pour aller comment
c'était comme ça dans une maison grès à
la guitare c'est vraiment une chanson
pour nous et pour nous comme vous dites
vous pouvez pas cacher que vous avez un
jean claude il nous a dit vous faudra
chanter pour les gens puis comme je les
aime bien et on l'a répété toute la
raison quand même chanson qu'il va faire
son chemin encore que beaucoup de
personnes la connaît sa pensée gré à ce
point autant d'amis ou quand même elle
est enregistrée sur un disque depuis il
ya toute l'industrie du disque et en ml
ou penser de ce patron qui
vous vous étiez toujours grecque et vous
êtes venu un pâtre grec n'ont pas un
métier qu'on en parlera du [ __ ] tout
à l'heure mais c'est le pâtre grec le
voyageur l'homme lob du soleil les
lézards avouer que jeunes que j'ai les
troupeaux c'est vrai
mais disons quand même c'est qu'un
aspect de vous tous un bon aspect
seulement peut-être ce but il est le
plus agréable des verts mais il faut
travailler dans la vie vous intéressé a
tellement d'autres choses que ça mais ce
qu'on peut voir le petit tour que vous
avez fait pour exister dans la chanson
comme ça oui vous connaissez oui mais je
commence je sais comment ça s'est passé
voilà je sais que vous étiez à paris
vous n'étiez dans les boîtes à
travailler à côté de saint-germain
rencontrer les gars ont un garçon
disparu comme lori troll un oui c'est
vrai mais je pensais aussi à cette
trompettiste a
créé des chansons pour boris vian
maurice était triste je leur ai appelés
borie wild boys l'ami voice est en fait
que vous êtes rentré tout doucement par
la petite porte au départ je crois que
je n'ai pas trouvé de porte à porte et
je suis entré par parages parce qu'ils
étaient ouverts je suis venu à paris
pour changer de vie pour changer de pays
pour changer de famille et
je ne sais pas ce que j'allais faire
puis j'ai j'avais envie de vivre d'une
certaine manière j'avais envie de vivre
la nuit d'écouter de la musique de faire
des rencontres et c'est toujours de nuit
que se passe parce que les gens ont fini
de travailler est dans cette atmosphère
là les gens qui vivaient faisait ceux de
la musique soit de la peinture soit des
discours philosophique soit rien du tout
et j'ai dit va si c'est une des choses
que je dois faire et j'ai choisi de
faire des chansons parce que c'est un
peu à ta vie que je dois dire le mythe
des méditerranéens qui n'ont pas envie
un jour lot de chanter ça n'existe pas
vous avez une rencontre qui a quand même
changé beaucoup de choses s'écroula est
tout à fait par hasard car en cui crola
était une demie grande admiration ça
reste vraiment quelqu'un de très cher et
un jour par la suite d'un malentendu
d'ailleurs qui a tourné à notre avantage
on est devenu amis du journal un jeu de
dire même d'une heure à l'autre d'une
minute à l'autre et comme nous l'a même
après midi il avait rendez vous avec
edith piaf et qu'on n'avait pas du tout
envie de s'écouter de se quitter il me
dit je t'emmène chez piaf et je rentrais
dans la tanière de madame piaf c'est à
dire un monde extraordinaire et
merveilleux qui débouchait sur la gloire
le drame
le bonheur et la tragédie vous avez
suivi pendant un moment
partagé un petit peu d'abord pour
apprendre parce qu'on devait écrire pour
quelqu'un elle voulait que vous écriviez
pour elle quand elle vous a connu où
elle a souhaité vous faire devenir
quelqu'un un peu cette sortie quelque
chose croît l'allument avait annoncé
comme un génie un homme fabuleux et puis
quand je vais chanter mes chansons cette
chanson qui parlait de paresse de soleil
deux filles elle me dit c'est pas du
tout pour moi il faut qu au moins si
vous avez envie d'écrire d'avoir affaire
à moi de il faudrait vous connaissez un
peu mieux alors ça tombe bien je passais
le même pierre ce soir venus m'écouter
et je vous allez tous les soirs jusqu'à
ce que je comprenne un peu mieux ce qui
était piaf et quand j'ai cru comprendre
j'ai commencé à écrire des chansons
et
jusqu'à ce que j'arrive à écrire une
chanson particulièrement qui s'appelle
miller qui était une chanson faite sur
elle comme comme un grand couturier
c'est un grand couturier leur côté rires
pourrait faire une robe pour quelqu'un
qu'ils aiment et qu'ils admirent et
c'était sa mine d'or c'est pas une
chanson pour une vedette c'était
vraiment ma manière de dire voici le 6
pour moi ce qui est bien et de l'écrire
de chance ça a été un grand honneur
comme un mineur ça a fait le tour du
monde avec piaf et après la disparition
de piaf
miller est quand même un des grands
succès qu'on a toujours tendance à côté
de piaf peut-être ça vous a permis de de
rester un petit peu paresseux après
mineurs ça veut dire que quand on a
écrit pour piaf on a du mal après se
frotter aux aux gens du show business
qui
qui sont un niveau nettement plus bas
pas tous heureusement mais c'était
difficile de continuer à vivre
sa vie d'auteur de chansons
dans des fréquentations qui me
satisfaisait plus alors chez j'ai décidé
de voir venir et 7 cette idée de voir
venir a duré sept ans à peu près au
cours desquelles j'ai fait de la musique
pour le cinéma pour le théâtre j'ai joué
aux échecs j'ai appris à démonter
remonter une moto à ne rien faire et
dormir tard mais finalement quand je dis
je n'ai rien fait pendant sept ans je
crois que j'ai fait plein de plein de
choses et par la suite quand je me suis
remis à chanter je me suis aperçu même
que j'avais écrit un certain nombre de
chansons qui m'assurait répertoire très
abondants je vais faire très vite un
grand sauvoy des bons tous les
interprètes bien entendu ne sont pas
très en dessous il y avait des gars
merveilleux comme serge reggiani pour
lequel vous avez écrit et puis non mais
il n'existait pas en tant que chanteur
bono
qui a fait moi avons pris des chemins
différents
reggiani et et il est toujours un des
plus grands acteurs mais il chantait pas
encore essayée à reggiani qui m'a fait
revenir quand j'ai vu les génies j'ai
dix meilleures qu'il ya des gens
merveilleux ils se voilent à peine
écrire des chansons et puis vous avez
écrit quelque chose qui était un autre
coup de tonnerre qui existe est
peut-être le [ __ ] vont vous l'avez
chanter ça a été fini je n'ai plus pu ne
pas chanter c'est à dire que quelques
mois avant j'ai pris goût à chanter il
se passait des choses merveilleuses dans
la rue dans les facultés dans les
universités dans les usines et on
appelait ça les événements de mai 68
c'était une stèle a fait de 68 aussi peu
qu'elle ait duré et c'est je crois ce à
ce moment-là que j'ai plus pu ne pas
chanter parce que je voyais les gens je
commence à les aimer avant pour moi le
public est une chose qui est et qui
était entre les interprètes pour que
j'écrivais
comprends bien c'est très facile et puis
vous avez vu les gens
devant moi je les aimais surtout dans
ces conditions au fort iq et j'ai dit je
vais chanter ça va me
ça va me plaire un moment puis sampler
depuis sept ou huit ans ou ne venge pas
on est déjà les prochaines on fêtera le
dixième anniversaire de de ce qui s'est
passé en mai 68 et je crois que quand on
a commencé à écrire des choses
disons profonde toute sa vie comme le
[ __ ] moi je pense une chanson très
profonde un [ __ ] vous êtes allé
beaucoup plus loin puisque la chanson
vraiment en maintenance et chansons crie
alors que c'est pas le soleil c'est tout
le contraire d'un csc lazio serait mais
quand il donne la force des ferries
culte est un peu
ses idées pour qu'elles y avait partout
n'est pas besoin d'être de s'échauffer
pour aller à une chanson peut chanter
directement une chanson comme chanson
créée c'est dire que les chansons sont
vraiment une projection profonde de soi
c'est vraiment l'art qui traduit le plus
le côté émotionnel de soi donc partie de
l'écrit et où
prononce les mots on retrouve l'émotion
qu'on aille au moule écrite c'est pas on
n'a pas besoin de se préparer on a
besoin de se préparer pour tous mais
peut-être les chansons elles ont une
vocation plus direct mais coûte chansons